[Music]
mr. the planetarium
my wife has taken the children twice how
many kids you got I've got three and
when are you gonna stop making babies as
soon as I learn to have protected stuff
that is a simple and accurate
there's no rebuttal to that no rebuttal
that is what that is but I've never
taken my kids to the planetarium oh and
what tell me their ages again so I have
a 16 year old and a 10 year old 6 and 10
and I'm like a zero zero you know even
though it'd be nice nice to take her
because she could still experience yeah
yeah you just feel it yeah you know she
often she at 3 years old says this all
the time
daddy I want to be an astronaut really
yes nice I want to go to the moon this
is what she says all the time my
daughter who's in Japan this summer
ok Japan she loved Manomet don't so mad
at me when your daughter before she left
uh-huh so I saw her at the Apollo Apollo
Theater for one of our show what about
you yes and we were backstage and she
was like yeah I'm going to Japan this
summer and I went alright so here's the
deal
watch yourself don't go crazy
but go a little crazy she's in Japan now
but go ahead
so she said curiously because she likes
comparing the cultures the American
culture and Japanese culture not only
just the obvious stuff but subtle things
like how do people think how do people
what do people dream of right how do
they plan for a future and how does the
language capture that we're not certain
things exist in some languages that
don't exist in others depending on the
need to have that ability to express the
ideas and thoughts and dreams and
aspirations of a culture that's okay
because words are nearly containers of
things that you actually can associate
correct and if there are things to
associate in your culture that need a
word you will come up with a word for it
exactly so what she said was in Japan
when you ask kids what do you want to be
when you grow up nobody says anything
that is sort of rare and exceptional
yeah they might see a doctor or lawyer
whatever but they're not gonna say
astronaut they're not gonna say rock
star they're not going to say prime
minister where is in America when you're
young these are accessible to us at
least psychologically from a very young
age that makes it so it's an interesting
contrast and that can ask what's going
on in the United States that gives
people these the the power to dream that
way mm-hmm against highly statistically
improbable odds right right right so
maybe you need that so that the one in
the thousand becomes the famous rock
star or the Jonah SUV this cab thinks
he's great and you know what here's the
thing too cuz he's driving a Ford Focus
so they're tiny cab there's a tiny crack
on it yeah basically we're just like
excuse me